he wished me for the best of luck  absolutely Marla maples is ready to win  Dancing with the Stars and says she has  heard from her ex Donald Trump he's kind  of some support he wished me the best of  luck  absolutely and I so appreciate it it was  fantastic right it's so many friends and  family are reaching out it means so much  I haven't been able to respond to  everyone but I got to tell you I feel  all the energy and support prepare were  married from 1993 to 1999 and have one  daughter together all these years so now  I've got to get into that passionate  part of me again the Italians probably  is great because my daughter's about to  graduate college so I'll learn it in the  dance and then maybe I'll take it out in  the world just a little bit oh you think  you guys as for all the election drama  including when candidates go after each  other spouses well Marla has one message  a better place beautiful thirties you  know we're all good friends over